comunque lo sai già questo gioco
contiene dei jam scher ma grava poi
prima prendi per il culo ma tranquillo
appello a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuto
che sono video sono fatti jpg siamo su
one night air one piece 2 gioco per
bambini e ragazzi
da allora sono di nuovo qui anche se
l'ho finito perché l'ultima volta ho
giocato alla modalità normale esiste una
modalità in questo gioco che si chiama
hard boiled mode questa qui è
praticamente è la modalità impossibile
cioè che un casino da finire comunque
voglio provare punto hard boiled mode
che praticamente è la modalità per chi
c'è al pene duro quindi proviamo shade
dovrà esistere fino alle 6 del mattino
ok siamo ragazzi siamo partiti allora di
riuscire a fare sta roba sarà
impossibile lo so già tanto dov'è clan
eccolo santi perfetta addio alla beata
minchia la batteria si scarica come
niente lurido stronzi si chiama già
preso e passato un secondo ma che
sentite e non ne chiede il gufo merda ok
il gufo andato a [ __ ] perfetta e che
sono solo le 12 ma anche non solo 6 ore
ce la possono fare non so che sta per
sfruttare club lo sapevo lo sa chi è che
guardi che cazzo guardi ho giocato
talmente tanto sta roba che ormai
pensiamo allo stesso modo gli atlantici
adesso rispunterà di nuovo stavo
scherzando volevo dirvi in attimo che
cos'è
oh cazzo se quella roba oh mio dio alla
fermi nativo al primo stronzo che la
metà basta però dove flan di aiuto ma
[ __ ]
siccome non c'era abbastanza merda che
mi sta arrivando addosso portate prende
i propri bidoni pieni di merda e tirarli
che così almeno eravamo a posto cioè
devi avere 14 braccia non si può fare
sono coming attimo che proviamo a
rifarlo franchi calmo non fare michael
jackson che sei brutto è stata la roba
più orribile ma tanto mi appare trani a
passo tre volte non era ancora arrivata
luna è impossibile
il gufo dio sa mi chiama ogni tanto mi
accorgo del gufo che ogni tanto parte a
caso qui devianti lo sapevo lo sapessi
per uno guardato ammazzare la madre la
roba che devo fare è rimanere sul gruppo
ecco lo sapevo
in fondo
cazzo troppa roba non è possibile ma non
si può fare mai questa roba ciò è
assurdo che ci sono riuscito al secondo
tentativo a fare quella normale a
vincere proprio arrivare alle 6 del
mattino o è stata una botta di culo che
non ricapiterà mai nella vita mi volete
dire che devo guardare questo stronzo
che si che si caccia e ha ucciso in un
nanosecondo c'è se spunta il pagliaccio
veramente sono morto devo anche
controllare gu pure rat man
grazie tanto non ci avevo abbastanza
merda sì ma tanto dovrebbe uscire
ecco lo stronzo sapevo lo sapevo e via
che sul buco che mi stava a stuprare
dov'è eccolo ok sono arrivato quasi
all'una di notte e lunedì notte è record
per sé a batman come mai ho scelto di
fassa cagata ea suez
possiamo davvero la vodka possa di sta
roba no non possono anche mettere il
tappo alla bottiglia che ti incazzi cioè
dai c'è anche quello che sembra un mega
polipo uscito dall inferi di satana
ragazzi non so chi sia quel tizio che mi
ha ucciso prima marco secondo me i
ragazzi per lui ci vuole la master ma
come minimo non avete fatto notare che
qua c'è scritto morte sul sulle cpu b1
amica visto non ci hanno fatto il caso
ormai spuntare il mezzo che non esplode
tutto il computer talmente impossibile
luca ok allora sto fermo staff era un
suo fermo mai vera che non sfrutta il
pagliaccio veloce veloce veloce però
perfetto il gufo vabbè è un attimo
ok ok tanto bravi andate affanculo
no no stai a casa tua rosa basta vita ve
lo dico
porca la trottola [ __ ] che
probabilmente tua madre matera
presenterò imposti io non credo che ci
sia un essere umano che si è riuscito a
finire questa roba è impossibile se
ancora chiudere le cose che sono senza
corrente non lo sapeva molto sei bello
sto casino infatti una ceretta volete
dell'acqua attraverso addosso e perché
no no no no no
luca che bello che si sono fatte
ragazzino [ __ ] una donna di quella
madonna poi c'è l'audio a mille non è
che c'hanno l'audio basso mi spara nelle
orecchie suo urlo che faccia l'altro
ragazzi 40 adesso cioè cambia con lì si
gira mentre non guardo cioè assurdo
carminati non calarmi in attimo casa
stavo lottando carminati incamminati
caminati calcara mila harris calvin
harris chiudi bravissimo dov'è andato
dal tizio rosso di prima dov'è il
pagliaccio perché sono stato al 3 pari
ok devo ancora di fare all'una di notte
io ragazzi non posso
ma [ __ ] e adesso mi spunta di
nuovo lo so lo so lo vedi che qua una
donna rischia di quelle facce che c'è
tutta schiaffi dove tutte le facce a
schiaffi questa tv con gli occhi e
chiudi ti senti franti farina allora
facciamo una roba io ti regalo delle
uova troppo similmente toni e tutela e
affanculo non ti fai più vedere nella
vita di musicista e di tufo è un attimo
allora ho un cervello o due braccia e
sono un fa vj uno solo ok una roba posso
fare 90 è impossibile lega non si può
fare se all'una di notte sta crepando c
arrivare alle 21 e la vittoria di
spuntare saranno una [ __ ] quel gufo
chiuso cento vai vai vai aveva e veloce
sono le due di notte rega le due ce la
sto facendo ma è impossibile
e chi ragazze va bene sarà la ladra ci
serve più vodka adesso distrutta
ronald mcdonald perfette su misura anche
l'altro grazie l'altro dove lo lasciamo
a casa non discriminiamo no mica si deve
riavviare o perche c'e botta di culo si
è botta assurda di culo che ho appena
avuto non lo so no il buffo no ogni
volta nella parte aperta cv bastardo ok
ok
cosa stai facendo
perché quel naso non te lo infili nel
culo visto che a grosso che sfiga ma
proprio mentre o toglievo dove di
spuntare ma che tempismo chayes ma che
bel dentinho ma ha chiesto guardi così
che cosa hai visto la madonna
se tutto questo basta massimi sono rotto
le palle mi sono rotto le palle mi sono
rotto impossibile non si può fare la
cosa più assurda che io abbia mai
provato di tutta la mia vita sono
arrivato alle 3 credo e non lo so io più
di questo non riesco mi rifiuto di
rifiuto era la battuta più pessima e
trash che potessi mai fare in tutta la
mia vita con i ragazzi concluso che
l'episodio è stato per me un traguardo
essere arrivato quasi alle tre o forse
sono arrivato alle tre non lo so pero
che ai video vi sia piaciuto ragazzi per
ogni vi piace vi do un minuto in più per
me di resistenza anche se tipo me ne
servirebbero un miliardo un miliardo di
laika dal solito se video è piaciuto
lasciato momento mi piace anche la pace
di facebook e come non divido tratta una
descrizione segreti di stile tra civiltà
non possiamo vinto belle ragazze